[Music]
let's go to zach in slc utah what's up
zack
hey john thanks for having me on the
show you got it man what's going on dude
hey so stop showing my 12 year old son
was uh physically assaulted at school
last week oh that spot it's brought us
to light some some separate bullying
issues which we've struggled with
helping with your background in
education and mental health that you've
got some tools and wisdom to offer
because mine don't seem to be working oh
man man okay so what happened at school
with the assault do you get in a fist
fight what happened
uh they were just playing basketball
some kids got
upset about him shooting from the side
of the key instead of the back out or
the front of it
he just uh got all the up in his face
and the teacher came and got him and
separated him as they were walking away
my son had turned around and
the teacher the kid bolted from the
teacher came up and called talked by
some a couple times okay
i just kind of know where so what
happened to well none of that comes out
of nowhere it may have been out of
nowhere for that situation what what
happened to your son i mean to to your
son what happened to that young man
young man out of school
uh
so
school didn't even call me a kid in the
school called
my son's
mother who were divorced from uh she
called me i went up to the school and
kind of stormed the assistant
principal's office and uh
got some answers but uh basically they
short suspension and
and uh they don't care i i insisted that
they're
they could be moved out of that class um
i don't know if i'm overreacting uh
yeah
you tell me
i think that uh
um well there's a couple things one i
don't like the fact that your head kid
got hit in the face and the school
didn't call you that's absurd that's
obnoxious and absurd um they're always
talk schools everywhere talking about
parent
um participation in the kids life
and that's not just when it comes to
math homework that also means in the
good stuff and the tough stuff um
clearly this other young man's got stuff
going on is there a possibility and
before i get into it i'm not ever
excusing another kid hitting another kid
in the face okay it's obnoxious it's
stupid it doesn't like we solve problems
but it does happen okay
is there a chance that your son
participated in this meaning was he
popping off at the mouth was he mouthing
on is there stuff that you can talk to
your kid about or is he a
um
a
is there a is are these consequences of
something that he may have participated
in
whether the right consequences or not
are they consequences
or is he victim of a senseless act of
like of teenage bullying here
you know he's uh
i'm not saying he's perfect or anything
but he's not the kind of kid to go
popping off or
or anything like that
um but he is a lot i mean
our entire school exists since we
struggled with people
uh being he's just like a magnet to
being jerked around uh
we've in fact we changed schools uh the
start of this year because of that to
hoping for kind of a fresh start kids
that
kind of pegged him as as some things and
we were hoping for
a change
and that's i guess that's the underlying
issue is it it's just a theme and i
don't know how to address it
being objective and i know this is hard
because it's your son
um
and here here let me ask let me tell you
where i'm headed here and then
um it's gonna sound like i'm coming
after you and i'm i'm not okay
but when i look at a situation and
there's multiple multiple environments
and multiple groups of people and
there's one common denominator i'm
asking you is there anything objective
that you can say your son is
this is why
does he have special needs does he
have
fill in the blank is he contributing
like what what is it there
i experienced that growing up my son's
experienced that growing up and there's
some things that just aren't fair in the
world and there's there's some idiots
out there in the world and there's some
stuff that we were doing that was
contributing to it
so
is just looking objectively at your son
from from arm's length
is there anything that he's contributing
to this
you know i
the only thing that comes to mind i
guess the the one thing i kind of
struggle to connect with him is he's
just like super uh extroverted and
uh
different for me in that regard
he's kind of loud and
i mean in like a
not an aggressive way but uh he's just a
lot i guess of the day that i've heard
you put up before he said
so
i know this kid and he is me so yes
if it makes you feel any better he's got
a bright future maybe he too can be a
youtuber someday and uh wow look how
it's working out for me working up for
me
um so here
here's the the there's a couple of big
metas here okay number one
i would circle back when you're not
um and that might be now
there is a i'm storming into the
principal's office to find out if my kid
is safe
and it's obnoxious and it's
disrespectful that they didn't call you
both for him
that they're just gonna send him home
with that level of trauma
and without you knowing it that's that's
just bad pedagogy that's a bad um
bad child care
and
that they didn't participate they didn't
bring you along to say hey your kid's
been hurt here are some things that we
want to work on with your family with
their other family everything
that's number one so you have that right
and responsibility and you have that
moment when you charge in
now that that the smoke has cleared on
that incident i would love for you to
circle back with the school counselor
with the school principal and say
what am i missing here
this is we've moved schools there's got
to be something here that my son's
contributing or that
is making it to where other people don't
like him that i want to be able to coach
him on teach him on take that posture
and you may learn some things
they may say yeah your kid actually you
wouldn't ever think it but
he's pretty handsy he gets real excited
about thing and he's always bumping into
people and putting his hands on people
and for some kids that's a threat or
he talks a lot of trash on the
basketball court or whatever the thing
is and it may be none of this but here's
i'm going to do my due diligence as a
dad
am i contributing to this in any shape
form professors my son
the second thing is and this is going to
sound backwards and i don't want all of
the internet warriors to come after me
on this
but your son needs to have some sort of
discipline in his life
preferably through
whether it's taking jujitsu classes
whether it's taking some sort of
uh he's does he play any sort of after
school sports
well he did boxing for a few years okay
uh then we got worried about
tbi stuff and so we we stopped that
great so i would transition him to both
of my kids will start jiu-jitsu soon
i'll put it that way this is something
i'm doing in my own house here's why
number one it teaches them
discipline
and it teaches them when to and how to
it also teaches them to identify when a
threat is actually a threat and when
somebody's being a knucklehead
and it teaches them oh this is what
could happen
and i was a hot-headed loudmouth idiot
until i started taking
jiu-jitsu classes until i started
training with a professional mma team
and dude it changed my life and it
changed my life and made me infinitely
less of a hothead
i don't even consider getting in fights
anymore not because i can't handle
myself because they're stupid to waste
my time
they're absolute ways to my life right
and if one comes to me i'll be okay
you know what i mean but there's a level
of confidence that it sounds
counterintuitive i don't want to teach
somebody how to fight to avoid fights
there is something about teaching a
young person whether my daughter and my
son are both going to do this
they learn strength they learn
resilience they learn toughness they
learn discipline and they learn how to
walk away
or how to back out of a situation how
they had to go
all right cool man and they laugh and
they know it's not a threat to my ego to
their to their self-esteem whatever
because their ego and self-esteem and
honor are in other places
the third thing is is i would get
really clear about forgiving yourself
with about this because i can hear it on
you
how much
am i wrong
uh
how he's been
through some stuff he's pretty resilient
kid but
his life hasn't been perfect
no but i'm uh
you're hanging on to some stuff
yeah uh
i'm not sure exactly where where to go
with that but uh
yeah i'm sure there's some stuff i could
i could figure out
the kids getting bullied it's not your
fault man
and i know you don't believe me
you don't i know that
and
you hit get kid got hit in the mouth you
asked yourself what should i have done
what could i have done whatever
i'm telling you is man your kid sounds
like your kid ran into a hot head when
you when you say you experience bullying
in other places back back up where what
other
it brought to light bullying what other
bullying is he experiencing
yeah so he pointed out
that we were leaving the school
and he pointed out a kid and he
mentioned that that kid had been a jerk
to him asked for more details and he
said you know he'll walk up through the
halls and kick him or punch him or
whatnot
and uh this year so for example go ahead
go ahead
so earlier in that same class period
that same kid
and in that conversation this was a few
days before he got cold talked by the
basketball player
he told me that and i said well you got
to tell someone you got to do something
about it you can't just deal with it
and uh so that period that same kid
punched him once he said he needs to
stop he punched him in the back again
did you need to stop he did it again so
we went and told the teacher
teacher pulled him aside and talked to
him
um
seems like an insufficient response to
me and it just pisses me off that
a kid gets talked to for
to repeatedly
punching it i don't i just still yeah
yeah still still out of control have you
talked to the teacher about it
i talked to the principal
yeah
he basically told me that that kid has a
history of things like that and that
they're working with counselors and
that's it i mean there's nothing to
there's nothing more going on
to distance into my son or or do
anything like that so what i would
suggest is having a gentle
kind but passionate conversation
in a non-threatening way but let them
know
i will bring legal action upon this
school if my kid gets hit one more time
we have put you on notice that these
particular children are hitting my child
and making my child unsafe at school
if my child's contributing in any way
let me know
if he's talking trash if he's pushing
first if he's bouncing bouncing around
into other people whatever
you let me know
but you are on notice now
and if somebody else hits my child i'm
gonna hold the school liable because
we've told you and you're not doing
anything about it
and you say that in a gentle kind way
and probably what they will say is we
can't continue this conversation anymore
because you've threatened legal action
and you say great
let me talk to the general counsel of
the district
okay i mean i guess you're right i guess
that's where the guild comes in but it
just feels like
yeah
yeah and i do i do identify with your
son
saying i i'm telling the adults in my
life the teachers in my life and they're
not doing anything about this
that's a scary place for a child to be
and the children deserve to go to school
and feel safe
okay
and so this is a three-prong
approach here
actually a four-prong approach
how often i'm gonna ask you a hard
question how often do you hug your kid
like daily good keep doing that let him
feel not hear let him feel that you love
him
okay
the second thing is has he seen any sort
of counseling or anything since the
divorce
uh yeah a little bit how's that
how's that going
i don't think you got a whole lot from
it okay
maybe y'all two go together and say
we're going to commit to healing you've
been through a lot i've been through a
lot we're going to go together
i don't even know what that looks like
but what i'm trying to say is he needs a
model for taking care of yourself
and he doesn't have that
and yeah it starts with you
the third thing is is get him in some
sort of jujitsu class physical activity
class gymnastics class a class where he
can use his body where he can grow and
develop self-confidence and discipline
and teamwork and learn
oh wow this is how this ends
and that teaches him a thousand ways how
to walk away how to back out how to be
confident how to stand up with a teacher
and say this can't write how to how to
take care of himself and number four be
very direct and intentional with the
school
when it comes to your child's safety
okay
okay
give that a shot man and
man how do i have that conversation
trying to dig in and see what what he's
doing without saying this is your fault
you have that conversation with the
school and with the teacher
okay
yeah you have that with the school with
the teacher and
a good skilled counselor that the two of
you all are going together
and you tell them i want to i want to
learn how to be the best dad i can and
so we're going to go talk to this
professional and i want to be the best
dad ever and maybe you didn't have the
best dad model for you
or you have done some things or said
something you want to be better at it
and better at it and so you let him know
um hey i want you to come with me to
these to these things i'm gonna i'm
gonna be learning some new things you're
gonna be learning some new things we're
gonna do this together uh but you model
it for them and a good counselor would
say oh what if we said this instead of
that right so they'll help with that
it's not pointing what are you doing
what are you contributing to this
um
but i think a good conversation with the
with the principal and the counselor and
his teachers will say this is how we
experience your kid
and there's that's hard because nobody
wants to say my kid's being bullied and
it's on me or my kid's contributing to
this because it's never okay to punch a
kid in the face don't hear me say that
at all in any shape form or fashion it's
never okay
and
that 12 year old's a child the one that
hit your kid is a child too
and so there's an interaction going on
between children and i want to teach my
son a how to stand up for himself how to
take care of himself how to walk away
with dignity
and
how to not get himself in some of these
situations and if it's happening over
and over and over and over again it
could be your kid's got special needs it
could be your kid is um got some is just
different he's tall he's short filling
the blank and kids are just ruthless and
mean
and that's where they need adults in
their life to step in and say i'm gonna
help keep you safe this is how we treat
each other so we talk and if the school
tells me oh yeah that's just one of our
violent kids we're working with them
not on my kid you're not
absolutely you're that violent kid isn't
going to practice being less violent on
my kid
that's the school's responsibility to
lean in and keep all of their kids safe
that kid included and your kid
it's a mess brother it's a mess